when you first learnt these I think in
saying you're right for you nine come in
when we first slap these I think we
distinguish between tree diagrams and
probability tree diagrams even though
even though we used boo-boos
both of them to solve probability
questions right does anyone have been
more the difference was venturi diagrams
probability tree diagrams yeah that's
right so tree diagrams are the simpler
ones okay for instance if you've got a
coin toss situation right maybe three
coins actually will just go to you right
now when you toss a coin okay there are
there are only two outcomes okay and we
assume sometimes the questions is
paranoia in says a fair coin right coin
it's not in the casino um both outcomes
are equally likely
yeah so you can draw out your outcomes
like so head tail okay
now this isn't just a regular tree
diagram because every outcome listed is
equally likely okay one is not life like
more likely than another see this
diagram sort of implies half half half
half half right on every branch of the
diagrams
okay but we could just as easily adjust
it right suppose you come to my casino
and all the coins in my casino are
totally loaded right and it's twice as
likely to get tails that heads so let's
go do that in advance right twice as
likely to get tailed
tails and heads so that means that one
of the probabilities for each one
2/3 1/3 right so once I put that on
there 2/3 1/3 to indicate that one's
range is more likely than another this
is now a probability tree diagram ok and
I guess it will continue down this way
you can see there's the whole set up now
more common than dodgy coin is that for
instance we've got I don't know three
items in a bag and you reach your hand
and two of them are one color and one is
a different color or you can multiply it
out as okay and here's the important
part these are these addition and
product rules what are they about
and we'll do Monroe sort actually the
product rule is for instance let's say
what's the probability of getting two
heads okay yeah if I work out the
probability of getting two heads
I need to take this one and this one
they're the only two ways sorry the only
one way I can get it by these two things
happening simultaneously okay now
there's the key word simultaneously
since these events are happening both
together okay I take their probabilities
and I multiply them hence products okay
so that's why I get 1/3 times 1/3 again
even though it seems for true if they
don't skip that line that shows that you
get that there's a perfect happening
here okay so there's my probability of
that event
now the addition rule is where you're
trying to get the famillies of events
but I'm not happening summer too soon
okay so for instance say it's
probability of one head
exactly one hit so now what options have
I got well there are two different ways
that this can happen I could get a head
first and then a tail right so I could
go this way this way so there's one or I
could go this way
get the tail first now I'm not rolling a
head tail and a tail head simultaneously
it's one or the other okay so since
they're not occurring at the same time
instead of multiplying them that's the
so in this case I would say take each
case one at a time often it's helpful to
put rackets around so you can see which
event is which this want to be 1/3 times
2/3 and then I add the other end because
that's what happens right which is in a
different water again even though it's
trivial try not to confuse your order if
you are right because these things are
actually representing different ok now
what are we going to end up getting
that's 2 minutes and that's 2 minutes
now these tree diagrams right instead of
laying out the sample space in a table
what you got as a sample space is all
the way down the end okay so sometimes
depending on the kind of question you
get you might like to find a helpful to
actually write out all of the options as
soon as you've finished drawing the tree
so you might draw head-tail ok and there
there is no sample space okay now it's
not so useful to you because you can't
say divide by for the total outcomes
because they're not all equally likely
does that make sense so that's why we
have to pay attention to these fractions
now the the server says use this kind of
diagram to solve probability questions
involving now I particularly want to
focus on this song
this part down here complimentary events
mutually exclusive events just means
what we've been talking about already
but you can't get a head tail and a tail
head at the same time they're mutually
exclusive it's one or the other
complimentary events whatever they do
complimentary events so the idea of a
continent event is the opposite of
something happening okay let me
illustrate it for you suppose I worked
out what's the probability of getting at
least 110 so that's different to exactly
one head right so this includes the
option I can get one head like yeah all
right can get two right so either those
are fine now how can we go about solving
as well one way of doing it is the same
way we approach this so take all the
possible options head tail tail head and
since I can have at least like four too
so go ahead hit as well so there are
three different outcomes multiplying
through and add them up okay so then
I'll get three things
it'll take the total but there's a
faster way right
instead of taking these three and adding
half if I did this right all the
probabilities of the whole sample spec
should add up to 1 so therefore what I
can do is Express this as the
probability of at least one head is the
probability of something else not
happening
namely this outcome down the bottom
right so the way I can write that is
like this 1 minus this probability but
it's called the work so the way that we
tend to write that is and you put a line
over the top or sometimes you'll see
really long okay so that means not this
happening that's why it's
it's me now another way we can say not
at least one head is known as right
isn't that the opposite of at least one
head that means you've got none okay and
another way to say that is having two
tails okay now do you have to go through
this whole rigmarole no I'm just putting
there just so you can see that logic
that I'm going through you could
probably go straight from this set up to
there I think it's clear that that's the
continent of this okay and so you need
to work out that probability 1 minus 2/3
okay and that's 5 points which is
substantially quicker and less
error-prone than taking all three of
them and then adding them up okay you
wouldn't believe how many problems come
up just because people can't add
fractions anymore because I left that
new 7 I don't need to add fractions I
mean you tossed in ok so pick a method
that's less air print hits faster all
right no I think that's it's in under
two probability so what I've given you
what you picked up when you weigh in has
a whole bunch of exercises question
come on
you mean that conditional probability
alright okay so with replacement and
without replacement is that we Matt yeah
sure okay
so I'm so far I've been dealing with
events where your first your first event
doesn't affect your second event okay
I guess if we take it as your example
suppose now
yeah these represent two different
colors and I'm pulling something out of
a hat
you should have to be careful with how
you write your second branch and the
probabilities that are attached to that
so let's just imagine there's three
objects one is this and yeah it's just
it's a coin with three heads and a coin
with details or something like that okay
so no let me get different colors so if
we took it as with replacement nothing
would have changed because you put your
take one out and then you put it back in
you still have three okay but now
without replacement which is your
question well let's think about what
happens if I've taken a head out and
there was one to begin with right how
many will be left none so zero okay if
I've taken out one head then there's two
things left right and both of them will
be tails
right so you can write this as 2 over 2
or you can write it as 1 you can see
these two events are complements of each
other they should always be complements
if they're coming from the same event
down here what what follows
why don't we got one tail right so now
there are two items left one's a head or
the tail so this will be a half and
really that's all the difference
everything else your addition rule and
your partner rule go exactly the same